in the city of San Francisco one of the
prettiest places in continental United
States law and order has been
effectively suspended
thanks to left-wing prosecutors
so-called quality of life crimes
essentially no longer exist people camp
on the sidewalk defecate in public use
drugs in broad daylight all without
penalty that's bad enough but even
crimes with clear-cut victims are on the
rise in some cases out of control
for part two of our week-long American
dystopian series we spoke with a local
business owner in San Francisco someone
who's struggling to run the store where
customers can steal with impunity here's
the conversation this is a day in the
life of Jill Dasani a
who runs a grocery store in San
Francisco's South of Market neighborhood
yes how often do people come in and
create problems in the store every day
every single day it's not an
exaggeration well the interview was
underway customers were filling their
pockets with merchandise and just
walking out of the store is shoplifting
an issue no yeah they decriminalized
petty theft in California but happens
every few minutes literally in our store
probably 15 20 times a day 20 times a
day oh yeah the decriminalization of
crime has been a disaster for this
neighborhood and if you don't prosecute
people but they just keep coming back
there's nothing's gonna happen this
isn't you know from somebody who shut up
when was the last time you came into
work and had a day where nothing went
wrong it's been many here shoplifting is
the least of dishonest concerns he's
been attacked by the homeless twice in
his own store one woman bit him when he
asked her to leave and she grabbed it in
today's San Francisco those who follow
the law are helpless while criminals
reign supreme this surveillance footage
shows a man breaking into the store and
stealing credit card equipment rang up
thirty thousand dollars with the refunds
within an hour the store's rear door is
rotting because homeless people urinate
on that's all from the acid in the urine
how often do you see people doing drugs
oh my god a few minutes before we
arrived someone had attempted to steal
some of the counterfeit money that the
solely a tapes to the wall behind the
cash register I see a lot of water
damage in the ceiling here what's that
this is low-income housing and that some
of them have issues and sometimes they
pass out and water penetrates the
ceiling it happens every month pretty
much how much do you pay in taxes a year
Oh thousands hundreds of thousands a
night it's a lot why are you still in
San Francisco with experiences like that
well because you make investments in
businesses and your homes and you buy
property and you can't just pick up and
leave
maybe he should by the end of the
interview the Sala gate was on the phone
with the police department
the man accosting us outside was
blocking the store's entrance and you
have angry people across the studio
can't afford it because they're living
in poverty whose fault is that you know
I'm scared for my safety it was his
second 9-1-1 call of the day san
francisco it was a beautiful place once